HARMING CHILDREN?
LOOK AT THE HARM DONE TO
CHILDREN.
>> Laura: ALL THESE PEOPLE SO
BE CENTERED.
I DISGRACEFUL, THEY WOULD SAY
THAT WITH POLITICS AS IT DID.
IS.
HERE'S KEVIN MCALEENAN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
THE ACCUSATIONS OVER THE LAST
TWO DAYS THAT YOU HAVE TO ENDURE
THIS, YOU ARE INTENTIONALLY
KEEPING KIDS IN THIS PRECARIOUS
SITUATION.
YOU HAVE SOME CHILDREN WHO HAVE
DIED AND CUSTODY.
>> IS A SAD STATE OF AFFAIRS IN
OUR POLITICS BUT WE HAVE AN
ACTUAL CRISIS AND SOLUTIONS ON
THE TABLE AND CLARITY OF WHAT
THE MEN AND WOMEN ON THE BORDER
NEED AND THAT IS THE THING WE
ARE HEARING.
>> YOU NEED BEDS AND FACILITIES
TO HOUSE WHAT YOU
PROTECTED, YOU PREDICTED THAT IF
PROTECTED, YOU PREDICTED THAT IW
PROTECTED, YOU PREDICTED THAT IE
DIDN'T GET THE MONEY TO
HOUSE THESE PEOPLE, WE WOULD
HAVE KIDS ON THE FLOORS AND
WHATEVER YOU CAN PROVIDE THAT
BORDER PATROL FACILITIES OR
INTENSE.
DID YOU GET THE BEDS?
>> NO.
>> Laura: THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE!
>> THESE ARE BEDS FOR CHILDREN
WHO ARE COMING UNACCOMPANIED,
RESPONSIBILITY AND OUR HUMAN
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM AND WE ASKED FOR THAT
FUNDING.
WE PUT A SOLUTION THAT WOULD END
THE CRISIS TO BEGIN WITH.
>> Laura: SO PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND, CROSSING THE BORDER,
THEY WOULD NOT BE PROCESSED AND
RELEASED, THEY WOULD BE
PROCESSED AND THEY WOULD BE
ADJUDICATED AT THE BORDER?
>> THEY WOULD SEE A JUDGE AND
GET A FAIR HEARING, IF THEY HAD
AN ASYLUM CLAIM AND ONLY
10 PERCENT DO IT WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO STAY IN THIS FLOW
WOULD DROP IMMEDIATELY.
>> Laura: IT WOULD DROP
OVERNIGHT.
>> WOULD HAPPEN TO 2014.
>> Laura: RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
RECRIMINATION AND POLITICS.
IT IS FINGER-POINTING WITH THE
MOST HEINOUS ACCUSATIONS BEING
LEVELED AT YOU.
IF YOU COULD GET ONE THING, ONE
THING TONIGHT, WHAT WOULD IT BE
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM?
>> ONE THING?
I WOULD CHANGE THE LAW ON THE
FAMILIES SO WE CAN KEEP THEM IN
CUSTODY.
THAT 70% IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
DAYS.
>> Laura: COMPANY TO HAVE IN
CUSTODY?
THE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS?
HOW MANY IN YOUR CUSTODY?
>> MOST ARE 13 TO 17 TEENAGE
BOYS.
>> Laura: WHERE THEY LIVE IN?
>> IS OUR POLICE STATIONS
DESIGNED FOR ADULTS.
>> Laura: HOW MUCH DOES THAT
COST?
I WAS THERE, THEY'RE NOT MEANT
TO HOLD PEOPLE.
>> WE ARE USING A HUGE PORTION
OF OUR OPERATING BUDGET ON A
CARING AND WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
ON THE BORDER PROTECTING PEOPLE.
THEY ARE DOING CARE,
TRANSPORTATION, HOSPITAL WATCH
FOR UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
>> Laura: WE SAW THEM.
FALLING OUT OF THE BOAT.
WE WITNESS THIS.
HHS IS SUPPOSED TO PICK THEM UP
AFTER HOW LONG?
>> IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE WITHIN
THE 72 HOURS.
>> Laura: DO THEY HAVE
ANYWHERE TO PUT THESE PEOPLE?
THERE IS NO WHERE TO PUT THE
PEOPLE AND CONGRESS WILL
ALLOCATE THE MONEY AND YOU ARE
THE BAD GUY.
SOMEONE EXPLAINED THE SITUATION
TO ME.
THIS IS REALLY RIDICULOUS.
RIGHT NOW THE PRESIDENT HAS
DECIDED, THEY ARE TRYING TO
IMPEACH HIM AND HE IS DOING A
COVER-UP.
THINGS LOOK LIKE THEY ARE
STALLED.
WHAT WILL THIS MEAN AS THE HOT
SUMMER MONTHS KICK IN?
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE?
>> EVEN THOUGH WE PROVIDED
SOLUTIONS TO CONGRESS WE WILL
NOT WAIT FOR THEM TO ACT.
I'M GOING MONDAY TO GUATEMALA.
WANT TO TAKE THIS FIGHT TO THE
CARTEL.
WE ARE BRINGING A CHURCH I
AGENTS WITH THE FORCE IS TO TRY
TO STOP THIS AT THE BEGINNING.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNMENT IN MEXICO WITH THE
SAME THING.
PEOPLE PROFITING FROM HUMAN
MISERY, WE CAN'T ALLOW THAT TO
GO ON ANYMORE.
AT THE BORDER, TRY TO GET JUDGES
DOWN THERE AND GET PEOPLE THERE.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE STORY
ABOUT THE PLANT'S AND PEOPLE
AROUND THE COUNTRY?
THAT WAS BLOWING UP THE INTERNET
OVER THE WEEKEND.
300,000 SENT TO FLORIDA.
PEOPLE OR MESSAGE ME GOING, WHAT
ARE THEY DOING SENDING THEM
HERE?
NOBODY WANTS THEM, NOT MY
BACKYARD SCENARIO.
>> I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNED,
THESE COMMUNITIES DON'T NEED AN
INFLUX OF MIGRANTS AND EVERYBODY
IS OVERLOADED ACROSS THE COUNTR
COUNTRY.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS TRYING TO
MANAGE THAT AND THE PORTER
ENVIRONMENT FIRST AND FOREMOST.
WE HAVE STATIONS THAT ARE FULL
AND A SOUTH TEXAS EL PASO, WE
ARE TRANSFORMING AND MOVING
MIGRANTS FROM STATIONS THAT ARE
OVERLOADED AND MOVING THEM TO
SAN DIEGO WHERE WE HAVE MORE
CAPACITY, MOVING THEM TO THE
SECTOR.
THAT IS HOW WE ARE TRYING TO
MANAGE THE CAPACITY ISSUE.
WE HAVE NO PLAN TO MOVE MIGRANTS
TO FLORIDA.
>> Laura: WANT TO GET YOUR
RESPONSE TO THIS DISTURBING
HEADLINE.
INFECTIOUS DISEASES, A RISING
THREAT AMONG MIGRANTS AT THE
BORDER.
I SAW A LOT OF PEOPLE COUGHING
WHEN I WAS THERE, A LOT OF
CHILDREN.
THE AGENTS WERE DONATING THEIR
OWN CHILDREN'S CLOTHES AND
BRINGING IN DIAPERS AND FORMULA
WITH THEIR OWN MONEY.
IT'S LIKE TEACHERS BUYING SCHOOL
SUPPLIES.
HOW BIG OF A CONCERN IS THE
HEALTH RISK BOTH TO AGENTS, TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT ARE OBSERVING
THIS?
>> IT IS SIGNIFICANT AND I'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT SINCE
DECEMBER.
WE ARE SEEING YOUNGER CHILDREN
ARRIVING SICKER EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
WE HAD AN OUTBREAK YESTERDAY,
THE INFECTIOUS DISEASE WITH THE
TEENAGER WHO PASSED AWAY ON
MONDAY.
A BAD STRAIN OF THE FLU.
WE HAVE SEEN MEASLES, MUMPS,
FOLKS AND CUSTODY THAT ARE
QUARANTINED.
IT'S A TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE.
WE HAVE A HUGE MEDICAL EFFORT
WITH CONTRACT SUPPORT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE.
THIS IS OVERWHELMING AND WHEN
SMUGGLERS ARE KEEPING PEOPLE IN
CLOSE QUARTERS IN MEXICO AND
STASH HOUSES, IT EXACERBATES.
>> Laura: 120 PEOPLE IN THE
BACK OF A TRUCK LAST WEEK I
THINK IT WAS, TEN DAYS AGO.
THAT IS TERRIFIC.
>> IT'S VERY DANGEROUS.
THE TEMPERATURE IN THAT TRUCK
WAS 98 DEGREES.
>> Laura: WE HAVE FOLKS ON
TELEVISION WHO ARE TURNING THIS
INTO A HYSTERICAL ISSUE AS FAR
AS BLAINE.
THIS WAS ON MSNBC.
>> THIS IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS
A COUNTRY AND AS A NATION.
WE ARE NOT BEING GIVEN ANSWERS
AS TO WHAT IS HAPPENING TO A
SMALL, YOUNG CHILDREN, TWO
TEENAGERS, TWO GIRLS, TWO BOYS
WERE BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES, FROM THEIR PARENTS AND
LEFT ALONE IN OUR CUSTODY.
IVANKA TRUMP, JARED, GET TO HIM!
>> THAT IS NOT HAPPENING.
WE ARE SEPARATING CHILDREN AND
MAY BE ONE CASE A DAY OUT OF THE
3,000 FAMILIES ARRIVING.
IT'S FOR THE SAFETY OF THE CHILD
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
AS A PROSECUTION FOR A SERIOUS
CRIMINAL OFFENSE, THREAT TO THE
CHILD, DISEASE OR SOMEONE WHO
WAS PRESENTING A FAMILY
RELATIONSHIP DOESN'T EXIST.
THE OTHER THING ON THE
HEALTH CARE, WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO TAKE CARE
OF THESE CHILDREN AS THEY
ARRIVE.
WE HAVE HAD OVER 150,000 KIDS
PROCESSED IN THE LAST THREE
MONTHS, OUR AGENTS FOR AMAZING
JOB.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THE NEW
WORLD THAT WAS RELEASED TODAY
THAT SPONSORS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WILL HAVE TO
GUARANTEE THEY WILL PAY FOR
THEIR HEALTH CARE?
THEY WILL PAY FOR THEIR OTHER
COSTS WHICH IS A LOT RIGHT NOW,
BUT NOT ENFORCED.
IS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
WITH THAT BRING DOWN THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION?
>> I THINK WE ARE LOOKING TO
TIGHTENING OUR ENFORCEMENT THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN ENFORCED
EFFECTIVELY IN THE PAST TO MAKE
IT HARDER TO BE YOUR LAWFULLY.
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT STEPS.